what we should draw here a triangle and
a quadrilateral and here's part of the
magic of this it can be absolutely any
triangle you like no special properties
absolutely any quadrilateral you like no
special properties in fact what I want
you to try and do with these shapes is
make them as unspecial as you can I
don't make it a parallelogram or even a
trapezium don't make it isosceles
actually now that I look at it that kind
of is ice also its but anyway that was a
mistake make them completely random and
then let's see what properties emerge if
we just do some very simple things so
for starters with your ruler I want you
to go ahead and measure these two sides
so that you can find the midpoints of
those two sides so a B and a C I will
point out you could do this with the
other with two any two sides that you
like but let's try and do it with the
same pair so that we are looking at
something reasonably similar go ahead
and find those midpoints let's call that
mid points P and Q now just by measuring
our midpoints so I probably should like
you also marking the fact that their
midpoints just by virtue of the fact
that they are midpoints we've created
something in here which has this magical
relationship with the existing triangle
if you go ahead and join this interval
PQ by the way as I join this up my no
note this is an interval not a line an
interval begins and it ends a line goes
forever in both directions does anyone
know what it's called when it's like
half half when it starts somewhere and
then it just goes forever it starts with
an R it's a very uncommon word we call
it a ray Ray's aren't used very much so
that's why you don't hear about them
very often okay
now have a look at PQ do you notice that
interval PQ has a relationship with the
rest of the triangle namely see this
last side down here the one we didn't
bisect do you notice that these two
lines are well they look like they're
parallel
right now can we prove that this is the
case and we can using the idea of
similarity and this is not a very
complicated proof look at it quickly
with me
because you've used one triangle to
create this and you've got these
midpoints right what you've created is a
pair of triangles whose sides are in
ratio let me say that again you've
created a pair of triangles a PQ in fact
I'm even going to say that in a PQ and
also the original triangle ABC
we have pairs of sides that are in the
same ratio right so I can say let's have
a look at our AP on a b AP on a B so
those two sides correspond to one
another in a little triangle to the big
triangle okay
well ap on a b is equal to because AP is
halfway right because it's halfway if I
wanted to prove this properly I guess I
would say AP on I'm going to divide this
up into two pieces like so but those two
pieces on the bottom are the same
do you agree like that's what I've
marked in because P bisect a be like so
so it's very straightforward logic that
this ratio is 1/2 but by exactly the
same process so I'm gonna say similarly
since it is exactly the same I can say
that of the other sides over here aq and
AC so I'm gonna say aq on a c equals 1/2
right so now what I've established is
that corresponding sides are in the same
ratio yeah
so aq on AC so I've got those
corresponding sides in proportion now to
prove similarity I need one more piece
of information there's two different way
I could go have a look at the diagram
and you tell me what other piece of
information could I add to this because
this is not enough on its own that would
give me similarity does anyone see it I
see it yeah fantastic right up the top
there angle what is it and go you could
call it angle a I suppose but more I
think it's better to call it by its real
in name so BAC or PAQ that angle is in
both triangles okay so I'm going to go
ahead and say angle BAC is common okay
so what that means is that now I can
state that these two are similar ap oops
two A's is not helpful now what's the
reason by the way what's a nice to see
two way to say this it's not that all
the sides that correspond are in the
same proportion because I don't actually
know that I only know two pairs I've got
two pairs and I've got an angle so how
would you read that so if I were proving
congruent I would say si s right
just as a quick note the reason why for
congruence were okay with just
abbreviations for with similarity excuse
me
we like words and I'm going to give you
the words in a second the reason why is
because in congruence when you're
talking about the features like the
sides or the angles you always mean
they're equal right when you say si s
you mean this side of the side or equal
this angle this angle this side this
side all equal but I'm saying different
things about the sides here then I am
from the angles when it comes to
similarity so here's a nice succinct way
to say it
sides about now that word about I'm
gonna underline because in mathematics
about means something different
something means something more technical
and specific it means on on either side
or surrounding so science about equal
angles since they're about the same
they're about they surround the same
angle they are automatically correspond
sides about equal angles are in
proportion
do you see that in seven words I've
captured everything about what I stated
here what's equal and what's in the same
ratio you could say in the same ratio if
you like but I prefer saying one word
rather than three
okay now I've proved this similar but
that was not what I set out to prove
what I was setting out to prove was the
PQ is parallel to B C so how can I use
this fact to demonstrate that how can I
use the fact that this similar to get to
the fact that they're parallel what do
you know about parallel lines what kinds
of information do we know about parallel
lines yeah okay if I had say coordinates
on here and I went ahead and I found the
gradients I would find that they would
match that's good what what else do I
know yeah okay so in addition to because
we know so many things about parallel
lines if I had a coordinate system I
would look at gradients unfortunately at
the moment I don't right now that
doesn't stop me from putting one on but
I might be able to do it without by
thinking about what Rogers suggested
I've got angles that correspond here and
here I also have angles that correspond
here and here and if they really are
parallel then the angles should be equal
right they correspond therefore they
should be equal can I can I prove that
that's the case from here how do I prove
it what will be my next lying what angle
might I refer to I've got more than one
choice but what if this actually would
you like me to choose little secret you
know how we're a bit finicky about
getting the letters of your similarity
or congruent Spurs we'd like you to put
them in order like we would like that if
you don't do it in order we won't
necessarily be all that upset but we
encourage it
because it means you have to think
geometrically about what's going on what
relates properly one of the advantages
of getting everything to line up is that
you don't even need to look at the
diagram anymore
to know what matches up to what because
you've done it all in the letters so
therefore I know automatically without
even looking back at my diagram or
presuming I did this properly that angle
a PQ is going to exactly equal angle ABC
because those letters correspond right
so I can say that these correspondents
sure enough there's a PQ and there's a
BC they they correspond don't it what's
the reason what's the reason
corresponding angles fantastic oh now
hold on corresponding angles are equal
but I don't actually know they're
parallel just yet that's what I want to
prove so that'll be my last line not my
first one come in anything yeah thank
you see this is the thing I know this is
the thing I've established I have proved
so now I can actually refer to that and
say I've got just enough space at the
bottom to conclude that hooray like I
was hoping there for PQ is parallel to
BC and the reason is because
corresponding angles it's a different
kind of corresponding by the way this is
in triangles and this is on parallel
lines corresponding angles are equal
sorry that's a bit smaller messy
okay so you can see what I was
mentioning before that similarity allows
us to show that things which seem to be
just magic like hey why does that become
that they have this foundation in very
very watertight deductive rigorous logic
and so watch how we can use this cool
beautiful result that if you like if I
summarize this whole thing what do we do
we joined up midpoints do you remember
that we join midpoints in a triangle
watch how that makes things even more
magical